nos primeiros dias depois que você se
foi
sentei no balanço vermelho que você me
deu
e como eu não podia fazer mais nada
aprendi esperar até o dia que você
quisesse voltar a balançar e te esperei
na primeira festa da escola pra você
os corações de cartolina com seu nome
dentro ensaiei aquela música do fábio
júnior e te esperei pensei no meio
daquelas várias pessoas que você ia
surgir para me surpreender que nem
acontecia sob nos filmes da sessão da
tarde
então até o último momento eu cantei
olhando para a porta e te esperei nos
meus aniversários
eu esperei nas formaturas
eu esperei no almoço de domingo eu
esperei
quando me fizeram chorar na primeira vez
na escola eu esperei quando sabiam cano
não sabem que o meu cabelo que era igual
ao seu
esperei quando o primeiro garoto me fez
me senti um nada eu também estarei
incansavelmente eu esperei guardei a sua
foto
guardei o urso que você me deu
esperei esperei o equilíbrio esperei
aquela sensação de balançar de novo
serei aquele empurrão para chegar mais
alto
eu esperei seu tempo e sua mudança
esperei até o último momento
aí você voltou disse que tinha mudado
disse que sabia que tinha feito de
errado
disse que nunca mais vai me abandonar
e aí eu sentia aquela sensação de novo
eu tenho esperado pra você eu tinha
esperado pra você
todos esses dias para saber que você
nunca tinha me chamado
eu esperei tanto que eu comecei a
balançar sozinha eu escrevi isso porque
no brasil ajustem 5,5 milhões de
crianças sem o nome do pai dela seu
registro e eu fui uma das duas crianças
eu esperei meu pai por sete anos e
quando ele voltou
ele me deu o nome dele mas ele nunca
quis compartilhar a vida dele comigo e
aí eu estava pensando no que eu ia falar
e venezuela mais novo então não passou
pelo processo e ela me mandou um homem
fazendo bem o que ela estava muito
triste porque ela tinha mandado uma
mensagem para ele dizendo que ela estava
preocupada e ele disse que não se
importava com ela e ela me mandou uma
mensagem dizendo tata eu estou muito
triste e aí resolvi escrever isso num
meu pai mas três minas para as pessoas
que são como a minha irmã e que ainda
estão esperando
obrigada
[Aplausos]